bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
des billets marqués canaliser les deux
millions et demi de parisiens qui sont
revenus de vacances se sont retrouvés
pris dans un réseau de palissades et de
parier
paris est devenue une sorte d'immense
chantier
[Musique]
pétrole non poursuite des travaux du
métro express en même temps qu'on
élargit avenues et boulevards on
perfectionne la circulation souterraine
et l'arc de triomphe à l'air prisonniers
de flèches méthane
c'est un fait qu'on avait rarement vu
autant de grues tendre leur bras d'acier
dans le ciel de paris
à la porte de penta les travaux du
boulevard périphérique offre l'un des
spectacles les plus impressionnants du
genre
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
élargir creuser jeter des ponts la
décongestion de la circulation de demain
est à ce prix mais la voirie n'est pas
la seule à se renouveler
paris se transforme aussi dans ces
quartiers l'ensemble architectural du
maine montparnasse par exemple est déjà
sorti de terre en novembre le premier
immeuble sera terminé bientôt la tour de
185 mètres fera concurrence au premier
gratte-ciel qui dresse heureux
croulebarbe ses 22 états
[Musique]
ici encore à la glacière tout un
quartier est en train de se transformer
[Musique]
un peu partout à la fois le baril de
demain est en train de pousser quel
sera-t-il ce pari de l'an 2000 il aura
peut-être un petit air de ressemblance
avec new york
[Musique]